good morning john i've noticed that a
lot of people who project a lot of
confidence
are able to do that because they have a
lifetime of experience
pretending when in fact they have this
like deep looming well of insecurity
always like just offshore
i mean me which makes it really fun to
publish a book because books get
reviewed it can feel a little like hello
i am a stranger and i am now going to
tell you whether or not the last two
years of your life were worthwhile
two stars now the reviews for a
beautifully foolish endeavor have been
very good but that doesn't mean that i
haven't run into some that have made me
feel bad so let's start out with two
things that i know
first critique is not the only way to
respond
to a piece of media that you consume so
sometimes what is in the reviews
isn't a critique it's just i liked this
or i didn't like this sometimes it's
just
it made me think about these things or
it reminded me of this other book and
that's great
until and unless the author takes it as
a critique
which it's not meant to be and the
second thing that i know is that
responding to critique
is a skill that must be learned it is
something that we are all going to deal
with in one way or another in our lives
and it's something that you are not
immediately good at it is normal
to be bad at it so here are some tips
from a confident looking guy
for how to handle criticism and turn it
from a thing that is
all bad to a thing that is at least
partly good and we're gonna do that by
talking about what i think are the four
types of criticism first there are
things that you know
are wrong at least to you like they
might be right in how they're
experiencing the world but like
for you no like sometimes people
criticize vlogbrothers videos for using
jump cuts and i'm like
okay no like we're not gonna stop that
and i saw a review of my book today that
said that the end wasn't exciting for
them
and i just like i think of the scenes in
the end of the book and i'm like
no that's like i disagree and if we
disagree then we disagree and i'm not
gonna try to like convince them that's
how they experienced the work now number
two
there are thoughts that might be right
or are right and these are of course
much harder to read but also they're the
useful critiques it is really important
in all parts of our lives that we
understand our weaknesses so that we can
work around them or so that we can
strengthen them if i feel like i'm not
doing something well i look for examples
of people who are i examine the tools
people are using to do things
i have not yet learned to do and that's
great and this is how
growth happens now it is really
important to be able to tell the
difference between category one things
and category two things
it's also really hard and the only way
i've gotten better at that
is by thoughtfully creating stuff and
thoughtfully engaging with critique
third kind of critique people just being
me if people are
in it just to find bad things about a
work i like to realize that as soon as i
can and just
discard it because it seems to me
clearly to be not about the work it's
about something else
it hurts it will never not hurt but it's
about something else a lot of times i
think it's just people putting the l on
the forehead and calling you a loser and
like
there's nothing to learn from that and
last and i put this in a separate
category though maybe it doesn't need to
be
our thoughts about the overall impact a
work has on people
and on society this kind of critique has
become a lot more common lately and i
think for good reason we'll get to work
and ask if it reinforces stereotypes or
indulges in harmful tropes or whether it
makes people feel good about themselves
or bad about themselves this is the
stuff that it hurts worst to get
wrong because you kind of can't undo it
and like the damage is there and done
now some people i think feel like this
isn't true critique because it isn't
engaging
in the craft it's talking about the
impact but i think craft
is ultimately all about impact it's
about using tools
to have an effect so critiquing craft
for me ultimately is about
critiquing effect and thus i think this
is stuff that should be enthusiastically
discussed so people can get better at
because here's what i'm always trying to
remember when i'm internalizing
criticism whether it's from a friend or
a random goodreads review i can either
feel like this person is telling me i
shouldn't be doing or have done the
thing that i did
or i can take it as literally the only
way
that i will ever know how to get better
it's not easy it's not simple
but in the right light it's a gift john
i'll see you on tuesday